C'est qui les diacres doivent être.
Ça c'est très important.
Non seulement car cette question doit être posée avant la question
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent faire,
ça nous aide à ne pas nous précipiter
pour voir ces personnes qui seraient capables de faire quelque chose
et penser qu'on peut les inviter au ministère.
Mais ça montre non seulement, je vous le répète,
non seulement l'importance que la question de l'être soit avant la question de faire,
mais c'est pour nous rappeler aussi que c'est quelque chose qui a été produit par Dieu lui-même.
Donc c'est quelque chose qu'ils sont,
ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'ils puissent devenir.
C'est une description avant tout des évidences d'une personne
qui a été remplie de son esprit et appelée par Christ pour exercer cette fonction.
Et donc ce sont des personnes qui ont été les produits ou l'objet
d'une agence particulière de son esprit qui les a qualifiées.
Donc à nous d'identifier ces choses chez ces personnes-là.
Et donc ces qualifications sont avant tout nécessaires,
elles sont solennelles, elles sont universelles,
elles sont non négociables.
C'est quelque chose qu'ils doivent être.
C'est quelque chose qu'ils doivent être, doivent être.
Et c'est quelque chose donc qui est universel.
C'est l'institution d'un rôle pour toujours, pour l'église.
Ok ?
Et donc qui sont les hommes qu'on doit chercher ?
Il faut qu'ils soient à plein de son esprit.
Donc là, c'est pour démontrer l'aspect non négociable.
C'est pour démontrer l'aspect des dévois.
Alors, une église, quand elle va rabaisser ses paramètres,
elle n'est plus en train de respecter la fidélité du Christ envers son église.
Et elle est en train de bouger avec des choses très solennelles.
Solennelle à nouveau, à cause du fait d'essayer de l'épouse du Christ,
de la maison des dieux, de Dieu vivant.
Ok ?
Et donc on pense à la pertinence de l'église.
Et on pense donc à des critères qui sont universels.
Donc ça ne change jamais.
Et il faut qu'on soit très attentif par rapport à ces critères.
Donc ce sont des qualifications nécessaires.
Ce sont des qualifications aussi, avant tout, spirituelles.
Et bien sûr, morales.
Donc c'est l'évidence de la présence du Saint-Esprit.
Et l'évidence de la présence du Saint-Esprit se montre surtout dans un caractère pieux.
Avant tout.
Donc on pense à l'individu.
Et non seulement des choses qu'on doit percevoir dans ces personnes,
mais surtout car parfois ces choses ne sont pas très évidentes à l'extérieur.
Donc l'opposé de ces choses peut être très évident à l'extérieur.
Ok ?
L'opposé de ces vertus sont très évidentes à l'extérieur.
Mais parfois, les vertus elles-mêmes peuvent ne pas être très évidentes à l'extérieur.
Et donc il faut que vous-même soyez très honnête, sincère,
en vue de l'aspect solennel de ces occupations,
pour vous dire, et pour dire à l'Église, et pour dire aux anciens,
en fait j'ai de la bataille avec certaines de ces choses-là.
Ok ?
Car ça peut passer de manière non perçue par les anciens et parfois même par la communauté.
Et donc, quelles sont ces caractéristiques ?
Donc avant tout, surtout basé sur l'acte 6,
être rempli de Saint-Esprit et des sagesses.
Donc bien sûr que la sagesse est une extension en fait de la présence de Saint-Esprit.
C'est celle qui va ressortir le plus dans la solution pratique
que les diacres vont trouver pour les ministères dans lesquels ils vont servir.
Donc c'est cette sagesse pratique de mettre l'Évangile en pratique
là où ils vont participer d'une réconciliation,
là où ils vont participer de la résolution d'un problème concret.
Et donc c'est une sagesse.
Ok ?
Mais avant tout, la question spirituelle c'est d'être rempli de Saint-Esprit.
Et donc, être rempli de Saint-Esprit,
on sait très bien, ça passe par les fruits de l'esprit
qui sont aussi illustrés de manière très particulière par ces vertus qui sont là.
Donc être rempli de Saint-Esprit,
donc passe par, comme je vous ai dit,
les caractères spirituels.
Donc c'est intéressant,
car même si les aspects particuliers ici mentionnés
peuvent ne pas être complètement en harmonie avec l'ordre et tous les éléments du fruit de l'esprit,
c'est plutôt des vertus qui sont particulièrement importantes à remarquer
pour l'exercice particulier du ministère des diacres.
Ok ?
Mais bien sûr qu'être plein du Saint-Esprit parle de la piété.
Voilà, on revient à cette appréciation envers la parole, envers la prière,
envers mes disciplines spirituelles constantes.
Est-ce que je suis à jour avec mes dévotions personnelles, avec mes dévotions familiales, etc.
Est-ce que je démontre être rempli de Saint-Esprit
par l'appréciation des ministères principaux,
de la parole, de la prière au sein de la communauté ?
Donc voilà, est-ce que j'apprécie tellement la parole, la prière,
à point de vouloir servir à sa promotion ?
Est-ce que j'aime l'unité de l'Église ?
C'est une question qui est les fruits de l'esprit aussi.
Ok ? Cette unité, les liens de la paix.
Et bien sûr, comme je vous ai dit à chaque fois,
cette soumission, car les services des anciens,
c'est de servir à travers la parole.
Et les services des diacres sont là aussi.
Mais en tout cas, les diacres, dans l'origine du terme,
ça passe par esclave, ça passe par service, ça passe aussi par aide.
Ça c'est très intéressant.
Voilà pourquoi l'exemple marital est important
dans les relations entre diacres et anciens,
car il y a cette notion aussi de la soumission
comme l'une des évidences les plus puissantes
du travail du Saint-Esprit chez nous.
Ok ?
Pour tous, pour les maris,
qui seront soumis à Christ en servant leurs épouses
par la direction,
pour les épouses et même pour les employés et les employeurs.
Et donc de toute manière,
la soumission, quand Paul va traiter
à propos d'être rempli de Saint-Esprit,
c'est la soumission qui va ressortir le plus.
Donc c'est d'être des personnes faciles à être dirigées
et voilà pourquoi ils deviendront des modèles,
des services pour toute la communauté.
Vous comprenez bien ?
Donc ça, c'est d'être rempli de Saint-Esprit
de manière très courte et résumée.
Et donc ensuite, être rempli de Saint-Esprit
et de quelle manière cela sera affiché
dans les caractères individuels de cette personne,
dans les caractères spirituels.
À nouveau, ce sont des vertus
qui ne peuvent pas être engendrées
de l'homme par soi-même,
mais sont, voilà,
une œuvre particulière de Saint-Esprit
qui a travaillé dans les vies de ces personnes.
Et donc, ils sont dignes, ok ?
Honnêteté, ce n'est pas la meilleure traduction.
Dans l'original, ça veut dire auguste,
vénérable, noble, intègre et qui honore.
Donc ce sont des personnes
qui à cause de leur piété
sont perçues au sein de la communauté
comme nobles, comme dignes, ok ?
Et notamment, ils les sont,
et c'est ça qui a une implication très importante,
car en même temps,
ils ont une espèce d'appréciation
de la dignité et de la noblesse
des ministères auxquels ils vont servir.
C'est-à-dire,
ce n'est pas que j'ai fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour me rendre digne devant la communauté,
c'est tellement digne devant mes yeux,
l'Église, les ministères de la parole
et les ministères de la prière,
que pour servir à une telle dignité,
à la dignité du Christ,
je m'accorde comme instrument à son usage.
qu'est-ce qu'il est Christ ?
Ou la Bible nous enseigne de manière générale,
c'est la dignité et la pureté des instruments
qui devraient être séparés pour les services officiels
du temple, du tabernacle, de l'Église, du Christ.
Et donc, c'est ce que Dieu fait avec tous ces instruments
qui ont un rôle officiel,
un rôle particulier.
Et donc, d'une manière générale,
tous les chrétiens sont séparés de cette manière
pour être utiles.
Et il y a la relation dans la Bible
entre la proportion de ma dignité,
de ma sanctification
et l'efficacité de mon service.
Et donc, dans ce sens-là,
c'est des personnes qui se présentent dignes
comme fruit et résultat
de l'influence du Saint-Esprit,
de la manière dont ils voient
la dignité des tâches,
de la parole, de la prière.
Et voilà pourquoi il y a cet impact,
il y a cet effet,
car je deviens officiellement séparé
pour honorer ces fonctions,
ces ministères, cette Église,
la maison des dieux.
Vous pouvez imaginer ?
Ce sont des entendants officiels,
des majordomes officiels
de la maison des dieux.
Donc, si on travaillait dans la maison du président,
on n'allait pas travailler
de n'importe quelle manière.
On aurait déjà cette sensation,
je dois me présenter digne,
je dois faire les choses avec dignité,
avec excellence.
Et donc, c'est cette dignité
qui démontre et qui est même
une réponse de la conscience
d'être à service du Christ.
À nouveau, avec les titres officiels,
ça redouble cette responsabilité,
mais l'évidence que cette personne
est peut-être appelée à ces ministères,
c'est car elle est déjà
en train de vouloir être un modèle
de dignifier,
dignifier les services
qu'elle fait au sein de l'Église.
Je veux dignifier la parole,
je veux dignifier mon Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
je veux dignifier les ministères des prières,
je veux dignifier l'accueil de l'Église.
Pourquoi ?
Car je dois me présenter digne
pour m'occuper d'une fonction
infiniment digne.
C'est clair pour vous ce point ?
Et donc, cette dignité,
c'est cet aspect des cohérences,
d'intégrité entre un service
qui est appelé un service officiel
de la maison des dieux.
Vous comprenez ?
Et donc, c'est cette dignité
qui est tout inclusive
et qui doit être au-dessus
de la liste entière,
qui va plus ou moins
représenter quelque part
la base et les fondements
pour tous les autres.
Et donc, comment cette dignité
s'affiche dans des aires très pratiques
qui sont liées au ministère des diacres.
Donc, s'ils sont là
pour faire la réconciliation
et avoir un zèle pour l'unité,
s'ils sont appelés, par exemple,
à visiter certaines personnes,
à promouvoir
quelques relations informelles,
une réunion entre
deux parties de l'Église
qui sont en dispute,
et donc, c'est très important
que ces personnes soient
sans duplicité,
qu'ils soient sobres,
qu'on n'ait pas l'impression
qu'il est comme il est maintenant
officier de l'Église
et qu'il sera un peu plus respecté
par la communauté
et qu'il va passer
et rendre visite
car il est peut-être
plus intéressé
par ce que nous,
on peut offrir.
Donc, c'est une personne
qui doit être sobre,
non donner au vent
pour qu'on ne doute pas
de ses motivations
car on a des cercles
au Mont-Brésil
de certaines églises
où les prophètes
ou les diacres
visitent les maisons et maisons
toujours en attendant
une récompense,
un bon repas
ou une bonne fête.
Et donc,
là où il va,
il apporte
la bonne communion
mais parfois,
va passer par
une bouteille de vin,
etc.
Et donc là,
on va commencer
à confondre les choses.
Et donc,
il doit être un modèle
des tempérances,
il doit être
sans duplicité,
pour ne pas avoir
aucune partialité
dans son service,
il doit être désintéressé
et il doit être fidèle.
Donc,
on va considérer
chacun de ces mots.
Donc,
d'être exempte
des duplicités,
c'est d'être exempte
des duplicités
avant tout
au niveau du cœur.
Donc,
les purs des cœurs
verront Dieu.
C'est ça qui est intéressant.
Lorsqu'il David,
il a commis ses péchés
avec Bathsheba,
et qui beaucoup
des jugements
retomberaient
sur lui,
lorsqu'il prie,
il n'est pas
préoccupé
avec tout ce qu'il va perdre,
avec sa disqualification
fonctionnelle.
Sa plus grande
préoccupation
quand il prie,
c'est Dieu
crée en moi
un cœur pur.
renouvelle en moi
un esprit
inébranable.
Car,
l'essence
des privilèges
des pouvoirs
servir à Dieu
avec intimité
avec son esprit
n'enlève pas
de moi ton esprit.
C'est tout simplement
cette pureté
des cœurs
qui garde
cette présence,
cette relation.
Et donc,
d'être sans duplicité,
c'est déjà
une personne
qui n'est jamais
en train
de vouloir
donner une impression
à propos de soi-même
qui ne soit pas
la vérité.
Ce n'est pas
une personne
très préoccupée
à présenter
une apparence.
C'est comme
Lord Jones disait,
on ne va jamais
rentrer
dans les cieux,
les paradis
par une porte large.
Et il disait,
la porte,
elle est tellement étroite
que ça ne va même
pas passer
toi et la personne
qui tu fais semblant d'être.
qui est en train
de se faire
et donc,
la réalité,
c'est que cette personne-là,
elle est sans duplicité
dans son caractère.
Elle est honnête
dans ce sens-là.
Elle est intègre.
Elle est transparente.
Cela ne veut pas dire
qu'elle soit toujours
en train d'afficher
ses faiblesses
à tous et n'importe qui.
Il est amendé quand même.
Mais il aura toujours
une personne
avec qui il aura
une confidence
pour être honnête
par rapport à ses batailles.
Mais donc,
il est sans duplicité
au niveau de son cœur.
ce qui permet
que cette personne
puisse développer
des relations larges
dans la communauté
où il voit
chez chaque chrétien
indépendamment
de leur rang social,
de leur origine,
de leur niveau
d'éducation,
d'instruction,
il voit tous
des enfants des dieux,
de la maison des dieux,
la famille des dieux,
personnes consultées
selon la chair.
Il est esclave
pour servir à tous
et pour promouvoir
l'unité de tous.
et donc,
il n'y a pas
d'intérêt double.
Il ne sera pas là
où peut-être
qu'il gagnera
la faveur
d'une certaine famille
pour régler un problème
au sein de l'Église.
Et donc,
son langage
ne sera double
non plus.
C'est-à-dire,
quand il va être là
pour essayer
de régler une affaire,
il va limiter
la conversation
dans ce qu'il écoute
et dans ce qu'il parle
au minimum nécessaire
pour protéger
la réputation,
de toutes les parties.
L'exemple de Paul
quand il va réconcilier
Évodie et Sainte-Ti,
on n'a même pas
l'indice
de quelle était
la raison
de leur division.
Mais un rappel
de qui elles sont
en Jésus-Christ
et comment elles ont
servi ensemble
pour l'Évangile.
Et donc,
quand on arrive
pour porter
la réconciliation,
il faut qu'on sache
dire aux personnes,
non,
tu n'as pas besoin
de rentrer dans ces détails.
Quels étaient
les problèmes principaux,
raconte-moi
de manière minimale
et nous allons chercher
de régler ça
selon l'Évangile.
Donc,
on n'est pas en train
de passer les mots
à gauche et à droite.
On est
sans duplicité.
Si nous sommes
en fonction
de l'unité de l'Église,
nous ne pouvons pas dire
être en fonction
de l'unité de l'Église
et s'aimer
de la division
en même temps.
Vous comprenez ?
Donc ensuite,
il y a cette notion
de sobre,
tempéré,
modéré
et donc c'est
un fruit de l'esprit.
La maîtrise de soi,
la tempérance.
Donc là,
on a traversé
les œuvres de la chair
et ça devrait être
un grand avertissement
pour nous.
Si nous sommes
un modèle
pour la communauté,
pour démontrer
comment se porte
une personne remplie
de son esprit,
nous devons nous rappeler
maintenant,
en plus d'un principe
qui vaut pour tous
les membres de l'Église,
on doit se rappeler
que par office,
je serai rédévable
devant Dieu
par rapport
à la manière
dont je suis en train
de me rapporter
aux choses de cette vie.
modération,
tempérance.
Donc il faut
qu'on soit
désintéressé,
donc ça va jouer
une chose
s'achévauche
à l'autre
mais ça va passer
par les motivations.
Et là,
l'avertissement
c'est contre
les grands sordides,
l'amour de l'argent
et c'est juste
de nous baser
sur les pensées publiques
des plus grands
exemples
diaconals
dans la Bible.
On va retrouver
un Christ
qui est en train
de laver
les pieds des disciples,
on va retrouver
un Jésus
qui a abandonné
la gloire céleste
pour servir
jusqu'à la mort des croix.
C'est de se rébaisser
pour pouvoir
promouvoir
la vie
et la sainteté
des frères et des sœurs.
Donc,
ce n'est pas
le désir
d'être en évidence
mais ce n'est surtout
pas
le désir
de s'émêler
à cette fonction
car il y a aussi
beaucoup de sectes
qui vont faire
usage
des relations
au-dedans
de l'Église,
des Églises
qui grandissent
beaucoup
pour créer
une espèce
de réseau
même pour
les business
entre-Église
et faciliter
la vie
des uns
des autres,
etc.
et ça commence
à tourner
autour parfois
de l'argent
et des fois
une personne
qui a une position
en tant que diacre
au sein de l'Église
il peut être là
en train d'être
tenté par ces choses,
par ses intérêts
mais plus que ça
en général
au sein
de l'histoire
de l'Église
ils aident beaucoup
les diacres
avec la gestion
des finances
faire passer les pots
raconter l'argent
en général
c'est confier
au diacre
ses fonctions
plus pratiques
mais quand on va
dans la Bible
par exemple
quand on pense à Jude
il était très intéressé
pour l'argent
et c'est là
où on revient
à l'exemple
que j'ai donné
car des fois
on va considérer
qu'il y a quelque chose
qui peut paraître
trivial pour les personnes
peut exprimer
un niveau d'excellence
qui peut faire promouvoir
les rames des dieux
et on va se dire
c'est pas une bonne gestion
d'investir
à cette manière
on pourrait utiliser
cet argent
pour
quelque chose
dans besoin
plus charitable
envers les pauvres
on pense à la femme
Marie
de Bethany
qui a cassé
les parfums
les plus chers
de sa famille
et Judas
qui disait
on pourrait avoir
une autre manière
d'utiliser cet argent
et donc des fois
c'est un attachement
à l'argent
qui empêche
que des investissements
généreux soient faits
pour la promotion
du royaume
avec l'excuse
que c'est une préoccupation
légitime
on pourrait mieux
utiliser cet argent
mais même
d'être tellement
accroché à l'argent
à point de ne pas le dépenser
parfois
pour promouvoir un ministère
ça démontre aussi
un attachement
à l'argent
dans les cas de Judas
il était intéressé aussi
à son profit particulier
mais
l'amour de l'argent
se manifeste
tant dans une économie
exagérée
qu'est dans la trivialité
de ce qu'on peut
dépenser
mais bon
l'amour de l'argent
c'est l'un des avertissements
les plus importants
dans la Bible
et les diacres
ne peuvent pas
être là
donc là
il y a des mesures
très pratiques
qu'on fait
dans mon avis
on faisait
si un diacre
particulier
était en train
de traverser
des moments
difficiles
financés
on ne les confiait pas
pour ne pas l'exposer
à la tentation
de l'occupation
de la récolte
de l'argent
ok
donc il y a des moments
où on va devoir
appliquer de la sagesse
où on va employer
chaque diacre
mais
de manière générale
il faut qu'il soit
désintéressé
qui sa vie
ne soit pas marquée
ni par la trivialité
ni par un désir
exagéré
et fidèle
donc fidèle
c'est un mot
vraiment très riche
là
sa fidélité
s'exprime surtout
voilà
conservant
les mystères
de la piété
dans une conscience
pure
donc cette fidélité
s'exprime
par cette
conservation
ok
cette persévérance
de cette protection
du mystère
de la foi
donc c'est quoi
les mystères de la foi
c'est à nouveau
cette appréciation
qu'on a
pour l'évangile
et pour tous les résultats
de l'évangile
et donc
si Jérusalem
pour la prière
ou pour
la parole
l'unité de l'église
ce sont les effets
de ma compréhension
de l'évangile
et les mystères
de la foi
en général
c'est cette unité
de l'église
qui est généré
entre même
juifs et païens
ok
à partir de Christ
et donc c'est la gloire
du travail de l'église
qui est devant nous
et qui est
les fruits de l'évangile
donc l'évangile
lui-même
doit être bien préservé
donc il faut
même si
les diacres
n'ont pas
un ministère
directement lié
à l'enseignement
de la parole
il faut qu'ils tous
aient une bonne compréhension
de l'évangile
qu'ils chérissent
l'évangile
et qu'ils sachent
que
tout leur comportement
sera
en harmonie
et en cohérence
avec l'évangile
c'est d'être sûr
qu'en tant qu'agent
officiel
de l'évangile
pratique
au sein de cette communauté
ma vie
doit être toujours
en cohérence
avec l'évangile
et donc c'est impossible
de ne pas avoir
ces vertus
et être en cohérence
avec l'évangile
ce sont les fruits
et même
quelque part
les conditions
pour la conversion
est-ce que
l'argent
est mon idole
ou Christ
est mon Seigneur
est-ce que
je suis gouverné
encore
par mes passions
charnelles
ou
le Saint-Esprit
va maîtriser
mes volontés
est-ce que
j'ai un cœur pur
car selon
les descriptions
du Christ
lui-même
d'un converti
c'est le pur
des cœurs
vers un Dieu
est-ce que
j'ai eu
les cœurs purifiés
et mon plus grand bien
c'est un cœur purifié
donc la dignité
donc tout cela
sont les fruits
de l'évangile
et je dois
à chaque fois
pendant ma conduite
au sein de l'église
faire des auto-examens
pour me dire
est-ce que
ma conscience
est pure
par rapport
à l'exercice
de ma tâche
et ça
à la fin des comptes
c'est la seule
protection
pour l'église
c'est la seule
protection
pour l'individu
lui-même
qui veut
s'émêler
en ministère
car
les thermomètres
de la présence
de son esprit
chez nous
c'est cet appel
constant
à préserver
notre conscience
pure
c'est qu'aucune
relation
de supervision
pastorale
n'a la capacité
de faire
une personne
véritablement appelée
elle est emparée
pour toujours
d'une crainte
devant Dieu
il sait
qu'il est en train
de s'émêler
avec les choses
envers lesquelles
Dieu a son plus
grand aile
les épisodes
dans la Bible
des corrections
sévères
se passent
notamment
au sein
de l'exercice
des fonctions
de la maison
des dieux
on pense aux enfants
d'Elie
on pense à
Ananias et Safira
Judas
et moi
j'ai cette expérience
avec cet ami
qui a étudié
avec moi
dans les séminaires
et
il était responsable
de raccolter
les fonds
de l'église
après
les deuxièmes cultes
qui étaient
les soirs
mais il profitait
car l'église
sortait
pour déjeuner
ensemble
et pendant
la pause déjeuner
il revenait
à l'église
il enlevait
l'argent
et à un moment donné
l'église a découvert ça
donc il était
écarté
il est venu
passer une période
aux Etats-Unis
pour avoir
une distance
de l'humiliation
qu'il a traversée
il a eu
une attaque
épileptique
il a tombé
dans un baignoir
qu'il avait
il avait
voilà
on ne dit pas
allumé
on ne dit quoi
oui
c'était ouvert
les trucs
pour commencer
à remplir d'eau
avec de l'eau chaude
bouillante même
presque bouillante
et il a eu
il a tombé
dans les baignoires
il est presque mort
il a eu
son corps
brûlé
de troisième degré
car il est resté
longtemps
et donc
c'était
interprété
bien sûr
par tous ceux
qui avaient
cette sensibilité
comme une espèce
de jugement
et donc
c'était très tragique
pour lui
les conséquences
pour toujours
de ça
mais plus tard
il a même été
assassiné
il y a un autre
homme
à notre église
qui était un diacre
chargé aussi
et lui
il a volé
quelques chèques
de l'église
et il a développé
assez tôt
après la découverte
du cancer
et donc
on sait très bien
que c'est biblique
et l'expérience
montre
que lorsqu'on joue
avec les offices
réels
si on n'a pas
la conscience pure
on risque
d'être traité
sévèrement par Dieu
surtout si nous sommes
dans des vraies églises
dans des églises
qui ont la préoccupation
et les ailes
d'agir
de manière pure
et sainte
et donc la conscience
en pasteur
ne peut pas avoir
accès à votre conscience
et c'est la seule chose
qui peut vous protéger
dans l'exercice
de votre ministère
d'avoir cette conscience
pure
et l'influence
de l'esprit
pour l'instant
j'ai pris fidélité
juste pour mettre
en emphase
cette conception
de conserver
les mystères
de la foi
dans le sens
de persévérance
mais on va revenir
sur les qualifications
familiales
et la fidélité
reviendra
et donc
les qualifications
relationnelles
donc ça
c'est très important
pour nous
les qualifications
relationnelles
elles sont
les implications
de ces vertus
des caractères
qui vont protéger
l'église
donc je vais juste
ouvrir en parenthèse
car ça parle
du ministère
des anciens
aussi
qui est du ministère
des diacres
car quelque part
il y a
une intersection
dans la pratique
quand on pense
à promouvoir
la réconciliation
c'est à dire
nous s'élan
mêlés à des
conversations
avec les membres
c'est comme
c'est que les pasteurs
vont exercer
en termes
des conseils
les diacres
pour éviter
que les pasteurs
soient toujours
en train
de s'occuper
des petites divisions
à l'église
ils sont là
pour promouvoir
aussi l'unité
et voilà pourquoi
la qualification
la présence
du Saint-Esprit
est la protection
qualificatrice
donc aujourd'hui
on confie
nos âmes
nos vies
même nos enfants
parfois
à des psychanalystes
des personnes
qui ont fait
des formations
pour chercher
à comprendre
les comportements
de personnes
et si nous voulons
être très optimistes
on peut imaginer
qu'ils ont ramassé
une quantité
d'informations
et de connaissances
qui dans la pratique
peuvent vraiment
aider les personnes
à corriger
certains comportements
mais nous savons
que leur objectif
n'est pas la piété
nous savons
qu'ils n'ont pas
la certitude
des connaissances
par rapport
au fonctionnement
de l'âme
car ça c'est
Dieu qu'il a
c'est une science
qui n'est pas
exacte
sauf si c'est la Bible
qui nous dit
la vérité
ce sont des choses
qui ne peuvent pas
être évaluées
par la méthode
scientifique
mais les problèmes
encore plus profonds
c'est
ces personnes
peuvent peut-être
avoir une connaissance
pragmatique
mais est-ce qu'ils ont
un caractère qualifié
et ça c'est un problème
au sein de l'église
aujourd'hui
car on a
relégué
on a délégué
les travaux
du conseil
biblique
à des hommes
et des femmes
au sein des églises
qui ont plutôt
une formation
psychologique
et peut-être
des conseils
bibliques
mais qui n'ont
jamais été
évalués
en termes
d'appel
des qualifications
les agents
des réconciliations
au sein de l'église
les conseils
donc d'abord
avant tout
les conseils
pastorales
ce sont les pasteurs
qui doivent le faire
mais même cette agence
pour aider
à la réconciliation
ce sont des hommes
qui avant tout
sont protégés
par la qualification
des caractères
nous on a su
récemment
d'un homme
qui a été
qualifié
par ses formations
et psychologiques
et des conseils
bibliques
et choisi
comme
les responsables
du conseil
biblique
de sa dénomination
et il passait
d'église
en église
sans beaucoup
de rédivabilité
et il était mêlé
à quelques cas
d'adultère
même avec la femme
dans des pasteurs
qu'il est allé visiter
et donc
quand on se pose
la question
pourquoi ça a lieu
c'est car
peut-être
on n'a pas posé
les bonnes questions
avant
de commissionner
certaines personnes
à la position
du soin
des âmes
donc c'est très utile
pour tous les chrétiens
de connaître
les conseils
purement bibliques
ok
mais ça
ne fait pas
de nous toujours
la personne
qui Dieu a choisi
pour être dans
la position
des conseils
de la communauté
car la protection
du caractère
va même conduire
une personne
à se dire
je pense que
je ne suis pas prêt
à traiter ces problèmes
je pense qu'à partir
de là
il vaut mieux
qu'on appelle
les anciens
les pasteurs
vous comprenez
donc nous
avons besoin
avant
l'exercice
des relations
officielles
au sein de la communauté
de nous assurer
de la qualification
de l'appel
cette personne
craint Dieu
elle est dans cette position
avec tremblement
et donc je suis protégé
vous comprenez
je peux être
vulnérable
transparent
vous comprenez
et donc la fidélité
à l'évangile
se porte
dans les relations
donc c'est
conserver les mystères
avec une conscience pure
c'est de savoir
que dans cette relation
mon objectif
c'est d'être fidèle
à l'évangile
et aux effets
de l'évangile
je ne veux pas
que cette personne
se sente bien
avec elle-même
s'il faut l'aider
non à promouvoir
le pacifisme
au sein de l'église
mais la vraie réconciliation
et la vraie réconciliation
passe par la reconnaissance
des erreurs
la confession
les changements
des comportements
et donc mon intérêt
c'est pas tout simplement
d'éviter les bagarres
c'est de promouvoir
la vraie réconciliation
c'est pas des personnes
très douées
pour éviter les problèmes
ce sont des personnes
véritablement intéressées
à la vraie réconciliation
donc c'est d'être fidèle
à l'évangile
c'est d'être sûr
que mes conseils
s'accordent
au principe de l'évangile
vous comprenez
c'est ce type de fidélité
dans les relations
qu'on doit avoir
c'est la fiabilité
dans l'exercice
donc là on dit
qu'on les éprouve d'abord
et qu'ils exercent
ensuite leur ministère
s'ils sont sans réproche
et donc là
c'est déjà la considération
des relations
qu'on a pu observer
jusqu'ici
jusqu'au moment
de l'ordination
on a tous ces temps-là
pour individuellement
m'assurer
de mon exercice fidèle
et pour que l'église
puisse s'assurer
de ça aussi
et donc
est-ce que ces personnes
sont fiables
donc des fois
il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui semblent avoir
une impression
de leur prédisposition
à service
déclarent leur prédisposition
à servir
mais souvent
lorsqu'on attend
les plus comptés
avec elles
elles ne sont pas là
elles trouvent toujours
des remplaçants
des excuses
elles ne sont pas constantes
elles démontrent
les désirs
pour servir
mais ces désirs
n'est pas
concrétisé
avec fiabilité
et donc
qu'on les éprouve d'abord
c'est pour voir
par exemple
si David
va traverser
deux ans
en prenant soin
des CD
des 400 personnes
par semaine
qu'il va faire fidèlement
ou d'autres affaires
et d'autres choses
qu'on est en train de faire
dans les relations
aussi
dans les relations de service
donc
de quelle manière
j'ai pu afficher
un caractère saint
et chrétien
quand j'ai aidé
la mobilisation
pour la conférence
est-ce que j'ai exercé
mon service
avec dignité
avec
non-duplicité
des cœurs
et bien sûr
que nous ne sommes pas
parfaits dans toutes
les choses
qu'on fait
mais
un indice
de l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit
c'est que lorsqu'on rate
comment on agit vite
pour régler la chose
pour demander
pardon
pour dire
cet épisode
ne représente pas
la manière
dont je dois exercer
mon ministère
comprenez
et donc là
est-ce qu'il y a
de la constance
de la fidélité
dans le sens
des fiabilités
est-ce que les personnes
peuvent compter
avec moi
avec constance
sans réproche
dans les relations
et donc là
c'est cette relation
à nouveau
c'est pas parfaite
mais c'est clairement
au-dessus de la moyenne
ce sont des personnes
des simples relations
pas hypersensibles
des personnes
qui
qui n'ont pas besoin
d'afficher
leur dignité
car c'est très naturel
et en même temps
des personnes
qui ne sont pas
très hypersensibles
si jamais
ils doivent absorber
quelques impacts
car tous ceux
qui sont dans les positions
officielles de service
vont s'offrir l'impact
et donc il faut
qu'on se demande
si dans les relations
je suis sans réproche
il faut regarder
les Christ
les diacres suprêmes
et nous demander
de quelle manière
il réagissait
quand il était
en train de développer
ses ministères
des réconciliations
parfois attaqué
parfois mal compris
mais constant
dans son humilité
dans son service
comme esclave
les rois serviteurs
et donc là
il faut
qu'on se demande
donc là
c'est d'être
l'objet de la grâce
des dieux
identifié
comme un chrétien
au-dessus de la moyenne
des relations faciles
donc moi
je ne fais pas
très souvent
beaucoup de blagues
avec les personnes
autour de moi
car je sais
que plusieurs personnes
peuvent être
un peu plus sensibles
et comprendre
mauvaisement
mes intentions
par contre
je me sens
beaucoup plus libre
quand j'identifie
une personne
qui saura rigoler
de soi-même
avec nous
qui va porter
de la légèreté
dans nos relations
et donc
c'est d'être
sans réproche
en termes
des relations faciles
mais surtout
d'afficher
cette dignité
des caractères
constamment
dans nos relations
voilà
est-ce que vous avez
des questions
sur ces qualifications
oui
c'est une très bonne question
on reviendra après
mais
il y aura des personnes
qui viendront
vers les anciens
en disant
je crois être appelé
au ministère diaconal
donc à chaque fois
que cela arrive
même pour les anciens
l'église doit
donner une réponse
légitime
peut-être qu'on n'a pas
encore d'y voir ça
mais on va s'approcher
et on va voir
comment nous pouvons
évaluer ça ensemble
pour la plupart des cas
ce sont des personnes
qui sont déjà
activement
en train d'exercer
des services
et des ministères
de manière très responsable
et très volontaire
et là
l'évidence
elle est déjà là
pour les anciens
et pour la communauté
donc
c'est déjà
ça fait déjà partie
d'une période probatoire
malheureusement
des fois
l'effet que ce soit informel
ça peut faciliter
et favoriser
l'inconstance
mais nous ne pouvons pas
dépendre
d'officialiser
les diaconats
pour pouvoir
chercher à constater
l'inconstance
car elle peut
motiver par les titres
faire plus d'efforts
pendant la période probatoire
mais il faut qu'on soit conscient
qu'il y ait de retarder
trop longtemps
l'officialisation
car c'est du désir
des dieux lui-même
d'officialiser la chose
ça nous rend
davantage
conscient
de notre responsabilité
si on est vraiment appelé
une fois ordonné
et cette crainte
en général
nous protège
pour qu'on exerce
de manière plus responsable
le ministère
et donc
d'un côté
il y a des choses
qui nous sommes déjà
en train d'observer
pour la plupart
mais de l'autre côté
je pense que ça sera
important
et c'est ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui
de déterminer
une date possible
d'ordination
et de nomination
pour qu'on soit
tous conscients
qu'on sera
devant une candidature
officielle
pour qu'on soit
devant une période
probatoire
accordée
ok
et donc
à partir de là
on sera plus conscient
de ça
ça répond à ta question
encore une question
oui
par rapport à la
conscience
pour
l'honnêtement
il faut
je ne sais pas
si bien compris
mais il faut partager
un peu les batailles
qu'on a
avec quelqu'un
avec une invitation
mature
oui
parce que
évidemment
à la France
en fait
on a
que nous
accès
à notre conscience
il n'y a pas
une réunion
personne
qui est là
oui
donc là
c'est une règle
générale
pour tous les chrétiens
si jamais
je traverse
une bataille
contre la chair
dans une ère
ou autre de ma vie
je dois toujours
chercher
un frère
plus expérimenté
si je suis un homme
sinon une soeur
si je suis une femme
pour chercher
de l'aide
dans la bataille
contre le péché
par contre
ici
on est en train
de traiter
quelque chose
qui aura
encore plus
de sévérité
en termes
du zèle
des dieux
sur ses fonctions
des fonctions
officiers
et
et c'est important
car
on est dans
un processus
d'évaluation
dans des entretiens
pastoraux
partagés
aux anciens
car
ok
tu peux penser
que moi
je suis appelé
à ça
mais je voulais
que tu saches
voici les batailles
que je traverse
dans ma vie
et donc
à partir de là
on va travailler
ensemble
pour voir
quelle est la force
si c'est une force
disqualificatrice
ou si c'est une bataille
qu'on peut surmonter
avec l'aide
de son esprit
et cette vulnérabilité
cette transparence
elle fait partie
aussi de la qualification
quelque part
c'est attendu
et donc
c'est particulièrement
en prenant en considération
ces éléments
qu'on vient de considérer
car ils sont particulièrement importants
pour l'exercice
de la tâche diaconale
mais
si c'est d'autres choses
il faut aussi partager
car
même quand on dit
sans reproche
c'est tout inclusif
c'est sans reproche
au niveau
immoralité sexuelle
et toutes les autres choses
et donc
il faut qu'on soit transparent
car
c'est comme
quand on essaye
d'enseigner
cette relation
avec nos enfants
on ne va pas toujours voir
les mauvaises choses
qu'ils font
mais Dieu va toujours voir
et à moins que Dieu
ne soit pas une réalité concrète
dans leur conscience
on ne sera jamais protégé
et donc
c'est cette relation
de transparence
qu'on doit avoir
au sein de l'église
et c'est cette évidence
que vous devez chercher
à trouver chez vous
combien gêné je suis
par rapport à certaines choses
et combien je chercherais
à me purifier
pour exercer cette tâche
ça répond
oui
tiens
lorsque
l'inconstanse
de la personne
est
le défendu en fait
de sa volonté
comment
se fait
ce que je suis
fait
bon
on va revenir
à cette question
de l'équilibre
entre
la responsabilité
de l'homme
et la souveraineté
de Dieu
donc
c'est évident
que le Saint-Esprit
exerce une influence
radicale
ok
et suffisante
pour qu'une personne
soit convaincue
de son appel
et qu'elle soit
suffisamment motivée
et en général
suffisamment puissant
cet appel
ou ces évidences
et ces gènes
dans la conscience
constant
pour qu'on soit toujours
en train de renouveler
nos voeux
et les dynamismes
de notre service
donc même cette conviction
elle est progressive
et c'est une agence
une continue de Saint-Esprit
et en même temps
c'est clair
que nous participons aussi
à renouveler
ces convictions
nous devons cultiver
car dans tous les terrains
pour les services
c'est un terrain
de bataille
on n'avait que les dents
avant la chute
qui étaient en train
de favoriser
tous ceux
qui ont pour ça
mais
aujourd'hui
j'essaye de planter
quelques arbres
fructifères
dans mon jardin
mais c'est une bataille constante
à peine j'arrive
à manger
deux trois pommes
qui sont
juste un peu
touchés par les bêtes
et donc
c'est comme ça
dans toutes les aires
de nos vies
c'est comme ça
pour les pasteurs
pour les diacres
pour tous
donc il faut qu'on soit conscient
de la bataille constante
contre la chair
contre les mondes
qui va chercher
à distraire nos priorités
nos attentions
et contre
les diables
et donc nous devons
constamment
nous exposer
à cette puissance
qui nous a appelé
qualifié
pour bien exercer
nos ministères
mais c'est clair
qu'il ne manque pas
bibliquement parlant
des motivations
pour ça
la seule chose
et ça c'est une question
très importante
voilà pourquoi
je veux étendre
elle pour tous
la seule chose
qu'on ne veut pas attendre
de ceux qui sont appelés
pour les ministères
c'est qu'ils soient
dans la dépendance constante
d'être motivés
pour faire leur service
ça c'est l'un des plus
grandes erreurs
des églises
de notre génération
de sentir
les besoins
de tirer l'oreille
de motiver
par d'autres moyens
de faire
une espèce
de structure
pour des marketing
des réseaux
pyramidales
pour pousser
les personnes
à servir
ce sont
les serviteurs
d'office
les modèles
de la communauté
les anciens
et les diacres
ce sont ceux
qui
se sentent responsables
constamment
de trouver eux-mêmes
leur motivation
ils ne peuvent pas
dépendre
des nounous
car ce sont eux
quelque part
les motivateurs
de la communauté
et si on n'a pas
ces éléments
en ce moment
de la communauté
on est perdu
et voilà pourquoi
ça je vais étendre aussi
car ça veut aussi
pour la notion
des membres d'église
par exemple
nous on fait exprès
de faire un travail
très solide
au départ
des responsabilisations
pour qu'on ne puisse
ne pas dépendre
plus tard
d'être constamment
en train de chercher
à vous responsabiliser
on vit dans une génération
qui est complètement
l'opposé de cette réalité
on se sent dans l'obligation
toujours de comprendre
les manquements
de motiver
et d'essayer de comprendre
un nombre infini
des raisons
qui auraient pu
décourager
cette personne
à servir
on est plutôt
constamment dans l'attente
que nos excuses
soient acceptées
qu'on ne soit pas
très exploité
mais la réalité
c'est que nos paramètres
et nos modèles
dans les écritures
pour les diaconas
pour les pasteurs
ne nous permet pas
d'avoir ce type
de relations
avec les ministères
envers l'appel
et c'est ça
qui est mystérieux
au milieu de la foi
car il n'y a pas
une relation
des patrons employés
dans un certain sens
je ne peux pas
vous ordonner
à faire certaines choses
mais pourquoi
je ne peux pas
le faire
car je n'ai pas besoin
de le faire
car si vous êtes
véritablement appelé
les moindres indices
!
d'une direction pastorale
légitime
sera saisi
car les seigneurs
Jésus Christ
lui-même
envers les appelés
entendent dire
c'est à toi
de les faire
nous pouvons
demander
nous pouvons proposer
vous comprenez
mais nous ne pouvons
pas ordonner
il n'y a pas
cette relation
ni entre les pasteurs
ni entre
anciens
et diacres
à moins
qu'il y ait
une formalisation
professionnelle
pour certains services
mais la réalité
c'est que
c'est les Christs
qui agissent en moi
c'est le même Christ
qui agissent
envers vous
et il a cette connexion
des prédispositions
à service
c'est comme les anges
quelque part
les anges
ils sont toujours
devant les trônes
des dieux
avec la fonction primaire
d'adorer
mais ensuite
ils sont comme
des chiens
d'ordre
prêts à recevoir
la moindre direction
afin de plaire
les seigneurs
donc cet ordre
vient du seigneur
et ça facilite
la relation ici
et voilà pourquoi
c'est important
de travailler
bien ces choses
avant
avant de nous mêler
à ces choses
c'est un abandon
considéré comme esclave
des priorités
du Christ
et c'est un abandon
à un tel niveau
qu'on considère déjà
la vie perdue
et toutes les difficultés
qu'on traversera
dans la vie
ne peuvent pas comparer
ou être sentis
comme une perte
car on a déjà
tout perdu
pour servir à Christ
c'est clair ?
c'est ça la notion
des diacres
qualification familiale
donc c'est un homme
irréprochable
un mari
un père
irréprochable
un chef
des maisons
irréprochable
un intendant
donc là on voit
de manière très claire
les diacres
doivent être
mari d'une seule femme
cela ne veut pas dire
forcément
qu'il faut impérativement
qu'il soit marié
mais ça nous renvoie
à la structure créationnelle
pour nous rappeler
ce qui est
la dynamique
les mouvements
d'un homme
mature
envers la maturité
et donc
il peut ne pas être marié
mais
s'il n'a pas
la conviction
d'un appel extraordinaire
au célibat
il est en train
de se porter
comme quelqu'un
qui est à la recherche
de se marier
de manière biblique
pieuse etc
il est déjà
dans une conduite
où il cherche
pour se marier
une seule femme
il n'est pas en train
de tester
plusieurs femmes
en même temps
donc on voit
cette intégrité
déjà là
mais c'est clair
que ça pointe aussi
envers la maturité
attendue
comme modèle
et en général
les modèles pour nous
ce sont des hommes
mariés
ok
et pourquoi
cette relation importante
on verra
car l'église
est considérée
comme la maison des dieux
dans un certain sens
les plus élevées
d'enfants
non je plaisante
mais ça a du sens
je suis en train
de rigoler là
mais ça a du sens
car on doit
prendre soin
de plusieurs enfants
des dieux
en même temps
et il y a
un entraînement
incroyable
avec une famille
nombreuse
aujourd'hui
je peux le dire
qui nous aide
à un peu mieux
optimiser les temps
et savoir
qu'est-ce qui représente
d'aimer
tous
de la même manière
et de chercher
à fournir
les mieux
de nos services
à plusieurs personnes
différentes
ça nous aide aussi
à ne pas
gaspiller du temps
avec des personnes
qui n'ont pas forcément
si tant besoin aussi
cette sensibilité
de savoir
qui veut plutôt profiter
à cause des carences
très superficielles
vouloir
que nous
remplacions
la position du Christ
dans leur vie
donc il faut qu'on sache aussi
établir des limites
dans ces relations
et donc
il faut qu'il soit
un homme
irréprochable
c'est-à-dire
il faut qu'il soit
masculin
selon la Bible
quelqu'un qui va
occuper une position
de diriger
ok
donc là
pas les diacres
forcément
car son service
n'est pas de direction
mais un homme
il est en train
de conduire
d'être un modèle
ok
et il servira
à l'église
en ayant
une qualification
en tant qu'homme
un mari
irréprochable
ok
donc c'est celui
qui est à jour
avec ses responsabilités
envers ses femmes
qui va conduire
son épouse
diriger son épouse
avec la fidélité
du Christ
et avec
la provision
et la protection
et la direction
spirituelle
qu'il doit exercer
donc s'il n'est pas
à jour
avec cette maîtrise
de soi
qui est la plus importante
à point
de séparer du temps
dans sa routine
pour nourrir
spirituellement
son épouse
pour protéger
sa famille
pour être sûr
que les mauvaises influences
du monde
et de l'école
ne sont pas en train
de prénéter
très profondément
s'il n'a pas
la capacité
de gérer
cette unité
entre sa famille
et Christ
il ne peut pas
gérer l'unité
de l'église
et donc
conduire
en prenant
en considération
la complémentarité
les contributions
féminines
l'aide de la femme
il n'est pas
en chauviniste
on dit ça
en français
non
chauvin
ouais
ok
mais il conduit
comme les Christ
conduit l'église
ok
il est
un père
irréprochable
donc il est là
responsable
il n'est pas
en train
de déléguer
toutes les responsabilités
des enfants
vers son épouse
s'il est présent
c'est à lui
de corriger
s'il est présent
c'est à lui
de même discipliner
l'enfant
s'il est présent
c'est à lui
de donner
des directions
ok
et toujours
en harmonie
son épouse
toujours en harmonie
avec sa direction
même lorsqu'il n'est pas présent
donc c'est quelqu'un
qui est un chef
qui est un père
irréprochable
et qui est un chef
des maisons
irréprochables
c'est quelqu'un
qui ne sera
pas
un tyran
qui veut
ordonner
que son épouse
tienne
toute la maison
en parfaite
ordre
et nettoyage
s'il n'est pas
disposé
à participer
à aider
et à donner
les modèles aussi
donc bien sûr
que certains
de ces tâches
dans une famille
qui a les privilèges
d'avoir une structure
biblique
où la femme
peut rester à la maison
et aider
peut-être qu'elle sera
en train de s'occuper
plus de ces tâches
mais cela ne veut pas dire
que son mari
sera en tirant
ni dans ses exigences
ni dans son absence
de participation
et donc il est un chef
des maisons
irréprochables
pas selon les critères
du monde
mais selon les critères
publics
qui passent par
l'établissement
de certaines priorités
peut-être que ça sera
plus important
la joie
et la qualité
suffisante
de la famille
qui avoir toujours
la maison en ordre
là où les enfants
ne peuvent même pas
jouer ou s'amuser
donc il y a
des priorités
qui sont
bibliques
qui peuvent être
plus importantes
que l'impression
d'éducation
qu'on a reçue
ou culturelle
ce sont des choses
qu'avec le temps
on va apprendre
à développer aussi
un chef des maisons
irréprochable
en entendant
et là
c'est de prendre conscience
qui est tout comme
je prends
soin
de mon épouse
de ma famille
de mes enfants
et de ma maison
quand je suis
dans mon office
de diacre
je suis en train
de prendre soin
de l'épouse du Christ
et la maison des dieux
et des enfants des dieux
voilà pourquoi
la famille
est la base
car Dieu nous a créé
à son image
en tant que famille
la famille est la base
ou la cellule
fondamentale de la société
et la famille
est le modèle
des directions
et fonctionnement
de l'église du Christ
Dieu nous a donné
le privilège
d'habiter avec nous
ok
et donc
quand je suis en train
de servir
je ne peux pas avoir
des attentes
envers ma maison
que je n'aurais pas
envers la maison des dieux
ces principes
il est très clair
dans le coeur
de David
et Salomon
et donc
les niveaux
d'agréabilité
de l'environnement
des beautés
des soins
des netteté
on dit ça
ouais
toutes ces choses là
d'ordre
d'organisation
excellence
et surtout
les relations
je suis en train
de les traiter
avec les prunelles
des yeux des dieux
les enfants des dieux
je dois exercer
envers mes frères et soeurs
les mêmes niveaux
des patience
que je devrais exercer
envers mes enfants
peut-être je ne dois pas
le faire
des fois ça me manque
des patience
avec mes enfants
mais je dois avoir
avec les
mais la réalité c'est
que je devrais avoir
plus avec les enfants aussi
et donc voilà
les qualifications familiales
il y a cette citation
d'Indy Hamilton
je voulais juste demander
à quelqu'un
de les lire
en haute voix
c'est très puissant
et ça se dirige
aux hommes
donc juste si un homme
peut lire ça
avant qu'on réponde
à la question
qualification familiale
ta femme n'est pas
ta maîtresse
juste là
pour te donner
du plaisir
ta femme n'est pas
ta cuivre
mais
juste là
pour te faire manger
ta femme n'est pas
ta femme de l'âge
juste là
pour te donner
ta femme
n'est pas
ta mou
juste là
pour te donner
ce que je veux
ta femme
est honnête
et qui est
appelée
à un lieu
avec amour
et asservie
à ses collègues
ta femme
est la première
des yeux
de Dieu
et c'est par sa grâce
que tu peux
vérifier
de sa prudence
de sa force
et de sa compilité
voilà
oui
dis-moi mon frère
et
tient
oui
en ce qui concerne
dans le temps
il est
il s'occupe en général
de l'enfant
qui donne
qui donne des directives
à l'enfant
parce qu'il fait quelque chose
de mal
et qui reproche à l'enfant
ce qu'il faut faire
ou ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
et l'enfant peut s'amener
à voir le père
comme le méchant
de la famille
et
plutôt sa mère
comme
ou peut-être
en fait
le reste
mais dans le sens
où c'est le père
qui se met
à reprocher
à l'enfant
dans le sens
où il le faut
est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a
une façon
en fait peut-être
c'est pas qu'il y a
par rapport
au bout du diacre
mais ça peut
peut-être améliorer
la façon de faire
dans la famille
enlever son enfant
bon
bien sûr
que tout office
redouble
notre sens
de responsabilité
et devrait nous pousser
à améliorer
nos services
dans tous les niveaux
mais c'est la même
les mêmes mouvements
on ne doit pas dépendre
ou attendre ça
c'est les contraires
ce sont des personnes
qui sont plutôt
évidemment
au moins suffisamment
au-dessus de la moyenne
dans leur gestion familiale
et l'élément
d'unité
il est très important
car l'élément
d'unité
et de fidélité
au sein de la famille
et même
cette conscience
des maisons
des dieux
excellence
il est important
donc par exemple
la réconciliation
ou les ministères
de la pacification
ok
des diacres
il est central
mais on ne peut pas
on peut ne pas attendre
on ne doit pas attendre
la division
pour essayer de réagir
il y a un travail
constant
pour promouvoir
l'unité
pour préserver
donc mes enfants
partent à l'école
ou si je donne
comme c'est un principe
très occidental
plus récent
trop de respect
à l'espace privé
ce qui n'est pas biblique
nous sommes toujours
enrichis par la communauté
et on pense
que nos enfants
ont besoin
d'avoir leur propre temps
et parfois même
avec un portable
donc ils sont exposés
à des mauvaises influences
qui seront divisives
au sein de ma famille
car ma famille est chrétienne
ok
et donc
lorsqu'ils seront
qu'ils ne seront pas
élevés
sur des principes
comment
chrétiens
donc Christ
les mystères
la piété
est notre unité
tout comme il est
l'unité de l'église
d'accord
si
même au sein
d'une église
si nous partons
après les dimanches
pendant la semaine
et nous bouvons
des sources
variées
sur internet
nous apprécions
des ministères différents
on va tous écouter
des prédicateurs différents
rien que ça
même si c'est chrétien
a la capacité
de diviser l'église
même ça
combien plus
l'exposition
à cette influence
de l'école
du monde
et donc
la responsabilité
des hommes
en arrivant
fatigué
de leur travail
c'est de s'assurer
qu'il est en train
de travailler
constamment
pour réagir
aux mauvaises influences
!
et pour promouvoir
une unité commune
et donc
un homme
qui n'est pas qualifié
lorsqu'il est
présenté
devant
les êtres
envers qui
il devrait avoir
l'allégeance
la plus naturelle
des services
ses enfants
et son épouse
il n'est pas qualifié
pour les faire
au sein de l'église
et donc la réalité
c'est qu'il y a
un travail constant
que les hommes
doivent faire
pour être
les modèles
de ces choses
y compris
un modèle
pour la famille
de l'importance
de chérir
les réunions
de prière
d'enseignement
budique
que l'église est là
c'est lui
qui va aider
même ses enfants
à chérir sa position
en tant que diacre
et pour chérir
sa position
en tant que diacre
il faut qu'il soit
vu par sa famille
comme un officier
de la promotion
de la parole
de la prière
et il faut donc
que cette personne
soit une personne
des prières
et des méditations
publiques
au sein de sa maison
et dans sa relation
avec l'église
et donc
c'est très important
de voir la cohérence
de ces principes
et la famille
étant
l'environnement
des bases
d'évaluation
pour qu'on voit aussi
ce comportement
à l'église
et donc ça ouvre aussi
une application
très pratique
et c'est un mystère
pour moi
honnêtement
car je viens
d'une autre culture
mais dans ma culture
la pratique
de l'hospitalité
elle est vraiment
très constante
je pense qu'on a développé
quelque chose
de très beau
dans notre église
mais au départ
de mon expérience
ici en France
ça a pris longtemps
pour que je sois
invité chez quelqu'un
je sais qu'aujourd'hui
c'est plus difficile
car on est nombreux
mais
si l'hospitalité
n'est pas pratiquée
cette personne
n'est pas en train
de donner l'opportunité
à la communauté
de contempler
la manière
dont sa maison
est gérée
de contempler
comment les membres
de sa famille
sont unis
unis par l'évangile
et comment la maison
est organisée
soignée
etc
et donc là
c'est important
de considérer
cette dynamique
des relations
de l'hospitalité
oui
pour les qualifications
on est toujours
censé
penser
dans
certains niveaux
de l'acheter
mais est-ce que
l'excès
de fermeture
aussi
ça peut être
une disposition
tu peux répéter
on est un excès
de fermeture
à la maison
dans la manière
comme je gère
ma famille
ça peut être
aussi
qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire par excès
de fermeture
c'est l'hérité
voilà
ça dépend
je ne sais pas
en fait là
comment on peut juger
ce type de choses
la bible
elle nous appelle
à vivre la joie
de la vie
et de la foi chrétienne
c'est ça que j'ai trouvé
toujours très intéressant
dans les ministères
d'assistir
qui était très ferme
dans ses convictions
qui était toujours
pour la discipline
même physique
des enfants
mais qui en même temps
c'était quelqu'un
qui aimait
inculquer
ça c'est dit en français
chez ses enfants
la bonté
des dieux
par les bonnes choses
qu'il a créé
et donc il était connu
comme quelqu'un
qui savait
vivre la vie
donc il faisait
des sacrifices
par exemple
de son temps
de son argent
pour que ses enfants
puissent profiter
de ces mondes
de cette vie
des bonnes choses
qu'il a créé
on n'a pas tous
les mêmes possibilités
à ces niveaux là
mais on peut tous
faire quelques sacrifices
dans cette direction
le plus important
au sein
d'une famille
c'est qu'on
soit toujours
défié par Dieu
le même
par Christ
entre cet équilibre
très important
où nos enfants
ont la conscience
que la désobéissance
mérite la punition
car s'ils n'ont pas ça
ils n'ont pas
la catégorie
nécessaire
pour comprendre
l'évangile
et en même temps
que la grâce
du Seigneur
est infiniment
supérieure
au mérite
qu'on a
d'être puni
et donc
on va devoir
faire les choix
selon la perception
qu'on a
de nos enfants
est-ce qu'ils sont
trop en train
de négliger
l'importance
de la discipline
de l'obéissance
et en même temps
ne pas être
ni très recourant
dans une direction
dans votre direction
et c'est un défi énorme
mais il faut toujours
chercher
à faire un rappel
constant
et chercher
à trouver cet équilibre
et voilà pourquoi
ça demande énormément
des participations
directes
et des conversations
et d'observations
proches
de nos enfants
il n'y a pas
de méthode
de distance
de traitement
pour ces choses-là
donc il y aura
voilà
et même lorsqu'il y a
un enfant
on va se dire
mais pourquoi
cette fois-là
tu n'as pas puni
l'autre
car c'est la sensation
des traitements
inégales
c'est car il a démontré
beaucoup plus vite
et beaucoup
beaucoup plus
convaincant
des évidences
des répentances
et tu as été
beaucoup plus résistant
et c'est important
pour toi
de te rappeler
de ces principes
et donc ça
c'est
voilà
après
dans la pratique
on pourrait passer
des heures et des heures
avec un autre séminaire
sur qu'est-ce qui peut représenter
plus d'effermité ou pas
car ça dépend beaucoup aussi
des influences qu'on a eues
et beaucoup de choses
qu'on va devoir développer
avec plus de temps
la question
qui était aussi
beaucoup
une partie
était beaucoup plus
similaire
la question
de
le joie
dans ce sens
là
l'enfant
peut développer
en fait
une distance
par rapport
à son père
qui est beaucoup plus
ferme
sur cette chose
comparativement
à sa mère
ou
ça ne peut pas
avoir lieu
car
la femme
ne peut pas
attendre toujours
que les maris arrivent
pour pratiquer la discipline
elle est aussi
l'autorité
sur les enfants
la chose principale
c'est qu'on soit
toujours
harmonique
et constant
dans la manière
de les faire
des fois
les enfants peuvent
devenir un peu plus
rebelles
envers leur mère
et c'est l'homme
qui doit quelque part
redoubler
le travail
la seule chose
qui ne peut pas avoir lieu
c'est les bons policiers
les mauvais policiers
au sein de la famille
il a passé tellement
de temps
loin des enfants
que quand il arrive
il ne peut qu'il s'amuser
c'est pas ça
comment ils se sont portés
aujourd'hui
quels sont les points
qui méritent
d'être traités
pas forcément toujours
avec une discipline physique
bien sûr
c'est la dernière
ressource
que ce soit clair
mais on va régler
d'abord
ces choses
et ensuite
en tant de qualité
pour s'amuser
avec les enfants
donc
on doit aussi
être constant
dans notre évaluation
de ne pas créer
ces décalages
entre les rôles
du père et de la mère
elle est
elle est considérée
par la bible
comme une extension
de moi
une seule chair
ok
et moi
une seule chair
avec elle
et les enfants
doivent voir ça
donc c'est très important
dans la relation familiale
d'échanger entre les parents
et se dire
je pense que tu es en train
de manquer un peu plus
d'effermité
ou je pense que tu es
très exagéré
à ce moment-là
je pense que
Béat traverse un moment
difficile
il faut qu'on soit
plus généreux envers ça
ok
elle a un peu de tension
par rapport à ça
donc il faut qu'on soit là
très dynamique
dans l'évaluation des choses
et d'agir ensemble
en tant qu'équipe
ok
bon
il n'y a pas beaucoup
des distinctions
il y a beaucoup plus
en commun
que différent
entre les exigences
pour les femmes
on va traiter plus tard
la question
est-ce que les femmes
peuvent être officiellement
d'yacres ou pas
indépendamment de cette discussion
c'est clair que les femmes
ont une classe de services
ici précise
et
dans leurs services
il faut qu'on évalue aussi
chez les femmes
à nouveau
tout ce qu'on a dit
par rapport au diacre
homme
veut aussi
de manière générale
par rapport à l'œuvre
du Saint-Esprit
envers ces femmes
remplies de Saint-Esprit
etc
il y a certains termes
qui vont réapparaître
comme cette dignité
vénérable
auguste révérend
noble etc
donc c'est cette intégrité
qu'on a déjà traité
et cette appréciation
des femmes
qui dignifient
le ministère de la parole
donc nous pensons
penser tout de suite
à ces femmes
qui voyageaient avec Jésus
et qui servaient Jésus
de manière féminine
car elles appréciaient
énormément
les ministères de la parole
la prière
les ministères pastorales
du Christ
et donc
en même temps
la Bible n'a pas
des réserves
elle n'a pas de problème
à
traiter non seulement
la femme
selon ses particularités
l'homme selon sa particularité
pour ce qui concerne
ses composants
naturels
la Bible n'a pas
peur des stéréotypes
car
tant nos vertus
comme
quelques faiblesses
peuvent ressortir davantage
selon
notre particularité
en tant qu'homme
ou en tant que femme
et donc ici
les femmes
vont jouer un rôle
important
soit
dans la compagnie
des diacres
ou de leur époux
dans ses services
diaconaux
pour la réconciliation
et
elles doivent faire attention
à garder
leur langue
ok
quand elles vont
traiter la question
des réconciliations
donc
l'homme
il ne peut pas être
double
ni des doubles langages
ok
il ne peut pas faire semblant
entre les choses
il peut être tenté
à être comme ça
et la femme
c'est intéressant
ici
dans les littérales
c'est de ne pas être
diabolos
mais
dans la définition
du terme
en soi
c'est d'être
médisant
divisible
diabolos
ne veut pas
toujours s'appliquer
à Satan
mais il est connu
comme diable
car
particulièrement
il est
les plus prééminents
entre ceux
qui vont
chercher
à provoquer
de la division
avec leur langue
des accusations
ok
et donc là
les femmes
là
je pense que c'est
la notion du comérage
qui ressort les plus
de manière très
stéréotypique
quand on pense
à la manière
dont les femmes
seront critiquées
dans la société
etc
et donc
cette classe
particulière
des femmes
elles sont marquées
par un changement
radical
dans une des pratiques
pécheresse
qui caractérisait
peut-être leur vie
les plus
avant la conversion
et donc
maintenant
elles sont
l'opposé
des diabolos
des médisantes
l'opposé
des divisives
et maintenant
elles sont des femmes
qui vont
utiliser leur langue
pour promouvoir
la réconciliation
pour rassurer
les personnes
du pardon divan
et donc
elles sont
l'opposé
de la médisance
elles sont
l'opposé
de passer
les mots
en avance
par rapport
aux cas difficiles
qu'elles sont
en train de traiter
donc voilà
elles gardent leur langue
!
elles sont aussi sobres
donc c'est à dire
tempérées
modérées
donc c'est modérées
envers l'abyssinance
c'est pas l'abyssinance totale
mais c'est cette capacité aussi
de se maîtriser
donc c'est la même chose
qu'on a vu
pour les hommes
donc les femmes
elles-mêmes doivent être
honnêtes
non médisantes
sobres
donc tempérées
modérées
fidèles
en toutes choses
et donc à nouveau
c'est le même principe
fiable
fidèle
et rempli des fois
les termes
ils donnent la possibilité
à ces trois interprétations
et donc elles doivent être
un modèle des fois
et ça
je reviens sur ça
car c'est un principe
qui vaut pour nous
pour les diacres
pour les anciens
il faut qu'on soit
rempli des fois
car des fois
on est en train de traiter
des cas tellement difficiles
et on doute même
que ces choses
seront réconciliées
seront réglées
par contre
nous devons avoir
la simplicité
de la foi de David
qui même après
son adultère
il va dire
Dieu crée en moi
un cœur pur
c'est la certitude
qui même la pureté
de mon cœur
peut être recréée
par l'œuvre de Dieu
et c'est ça
que nous devons avoir
avoir la confiance
que nous pouvons
exercer un rôle
efficace
dans la réconciliation
en tant que diacre
dans les relations
auxquelles on va toucher
et donc ces femmes
qui seront en train
d'accompagner
peut-être elles seront tentées
à partager les mots
ou peut-être
qu'elles sont les pouces
des diacres
qui sont là
en train de travailler
et qu'elles seront tentées
à passer les mots
aussi des choses
qui sont en train de se passer
dans la vie de certains
et il faut qu'elles sachent
garder la chose
soit en agissant
elles-mêmes
soit en accompagnant
les diacres
et la même chose
par rapport à la famille
s'applique à la femme
de manière féminine
donc bien sûr
en coopération
en aide
en soumission
à son mari
mais très responsable
envers ses enfants
envers la maison
envers l'intendance
de toutes ces choses
et donc peut-être
que parfois
et Poaché dit ça
assez souvent
je commence à frapper
énormément les hommes
et les femmes sont là
en train de célébrer
mais plus tard
je dois venir
avec des exhortations
pour les femmes
et je pense
que dans un contexte
qui parfois est marqué
trop par l'influence
du féminisme
peut-être que la phrase
que j'ai mis en avance
pourrait parfois
s'appliquer aussi
à certaines femmes
ton mari n'est pas
ton homme de ménage
etc.
et donc c'est très important
car ces stéréotypes
ils ne sont pas
que les essais-vues
parfois ils sont
en train de démontrer
la manière naturelle
d'organisation
dans une maison
et là
voilà
il faut juste
qu'on revienne
au principe biblique
pour la famille
pour qu'on puisse être efficace
à promouvoir
l'unité de l'église
avec Christ
qui va être aussi
la reproduction
de la restauration
de l'ordre familial
dans les foyers
et d'ailleurs
beaucoup de divisions
dans les familles
ont lieu
notamment à cause
du manque de respect
de l'ordre biblique
pour les rôles
de l'homme
et de la femme
donc ici
dans notre contexte
le travail des diacres
va passer beaucoup
lorsqu'on va produire
ou promouvoir
la réconciliation
de l'évangile
chez une famille
ou entre les personnes
ça va passer
par les rappels
et la restauration
des rôles
de l'homme
de la femme
de la famille
donc ça c'est
très important pour nous
et un rappel
de cette soumission
particulière des femmes
si les diacres
de manière générale
sont soumis
aux anciens
c'est clair
que les femmes
qui exerceront
dans une tâche officielle
à l'église
devront aussi
les faire
de manière très féminine
avec une attitude
constante
des soumissions
ok
on reviendra
sur les aspects
pratiques
et là
pour l'instant
on va faire
une nouvelle pause
après les questions
est-ce que vous avez
des questions
une question
mais peut-être
ça sera plus tard
répondu
dans le rôle
de dire
entre hommes
et femmes
il y a
un niveau
de
hiérarchie
entre hommes
et femmes
dans quel sens
on reviendra
sur ça
comment coordonner
les relations
entre les diacres
hommes
et les femmes
assistantes
diaconales
c'est exprès
c'est pas
assistantes
des diacres
pour pas forcément
connecter toujours
les ministères
des femmes
qui servent
sous
directement
au ministère
des diacres
mais elles sont
assistantes
diaconales
donc ça
on va expliquer
pourquoi on est
arrivé à ces termes
mais ça passe par là
est-ce qu'on a
d'autres questions
oui
oui Linda
par rapport
au moment
à ces qualifications
que ce soit
dans le caractère
par rapport
à la motivation
dont tu parlais
aussi
il y a des saisons
de vie
qui peuvent être
un peu
exprouvantes
et des changements
pour justement
cesser
que ce soit
cette motivation
ou le temps
comme
la condition
et aussi
les caractères
parce qu'il y a des moments
où il y a des preuves
des changements
comment faire la part
comment
oui
c'est important
donc
la notion
de l'appel
est pour toujours
la commission
elle est pour toujours
les possibilités
concrètes
des services
ça peut dépendre
aussi de la providence
je pense qu'une chose
qu'on peut faire toujours
c'est
de consacrer
en temps minimal
pour être constamment
en service
mais pas toujours
servir
dans les mêmes niveaux
qu'un jour
on a pu faire
ou qu'un jour
on désire
revenir à faire
donc
ces
transitions
familiales
des épisodes
de vie
ils sont parfois
une opportunité
aussi
pour que nous puissions
démontrer davantage
la qualification
en respectant
l'ordre
des priorités bibliques
car parfois
je dois plutôt
donner la priorité
à ma famille
que au service
à l'église
et donc
c'est
une suspension
pratique
dans le temps
consacré
en service
mais
c'est important
au moins
de garder
un petit contact
pour garder
aussi
la notion
de l'appel
et de la conviction
et travailler
au fur et à mesure
pour restaurer
ces possibilités
ça répond
à ta question
oui
donc voilà
à nouveau
les travails
progressifs
des scientifications
doivent prendre
en considération
les points départs
donc par exemple
si quelqu'un
qui était addictique
des cracks
et cocaïne
s'est converti
aujourd'hui
et qui fait
beaucoup d'efforts
pour arrêter
avec ces choses
mais
il a encore
un reste
d'addiction
chimique
et il fume
encore de la cigarette
je pense
que c'est déjà
une transition
et une évidence
de conversion
tellement puissante
qui peut être
même comparé
comme un avancement
une progression
beaucoup plus grande
que celui
qui fumait de la cigarette
et s'est arrêté
après la conversion
et donc
on attend encore
les jours
où il va couper
complètement
avec ces choses
mais
on voit déjà
clairement
beaucoup de progrès
et donc
c'est plutôt
la conviction
envers quelle direction
je cherche
à aller
et je suis résolu
et je suis en train
de prendre
des mesures pratiques
pour y aller
plutôt
que d'être
du jour au lendemain
voilà les modèles
les plus recommandables
pour ces choses là
c'est plutôt
la prédisposition
du coeur
combien facile
nous sommes
à nous laisser corriger
et à vouloir progresser
plutôt que tout simplement
être déjà
dans la fond des choses
il y a-t-il des raisons légitimes
pour ne pas s'engager
dans ce mode
de l'appel
ah oui pour une personne
qui considère
cet appel
ou une personne
qui est proposée
ou considérée
par les anciens
envers cet appel
oui donc
quelles sont les raisons légitimes
d'abord
être convaincu
qu'on n'a pas appelé
donc il y a
cette interaction
personnelle
être
clairement
en ayant été
confronté
à ces principes
non seulement
c'est dire
qu'on n'est pas qualifié
car Moïse
il a dit
à plusieurs reprises
qu'il n'était pas qualifié
et Dieu savait
qu'il était qualifié
mais
de présenter
des raisons légitimes
pour laquelle
on ne pourrait pas
considérer
qu'on est qualifié
pour ça
et donc
c'est juste
voir les qualifications
évaluer l'appel
et les convictions
en termes
et légitimement
peut-être
inviter
à évaluer
ou peut-être
voir qu'il y a
beaucoup en moi
qui s'achevauchent
avec les qualifications
des diacres
et peut-être
j'en appelle
plutôt
dans la direction
du service d'enseignement
ou dans le service
des disciples
envers les femmes
et là
on n'a pas
de service officiel
pour les femmes
en temps
qui est pasteur
ou pastrice
ou ancienne
mais
nous voyons
de manière très claire
dans la Bible
qu'il y avait
des femmes
qui servaient
plus
dans l'enseignement
dans les disciples
et nous
on a fait
même une liste
avec quelques noms
qui s'achevauchent
entre possibilités
pour les diacres
et possibilités
pour soit
un ministère des femmes
ou d'enseignement
d'enfants
ça répond à ta question
ok
donc
je vais juste demander
à quelqu'un
de lire
une citation
avant la pause
déjeuner
et donc
c'est une citation
un peu plus longue
mais qui va
voilà
il est certain
que
nous devons faire
cause de pardon
mais nous ne pouvons pas
effacer les conséquences
du péché
il ne s'agit pas ici
de tirer sur le blessé
les blessés
je dis simplement
que nous ne devons pas
renvoyer
précisément
sur la ligne
des fronts
et encore moins
le maître
à la tête
d'autres soldats
l'église doit faire
tout ce qui est possible
pour accompagner
!
ceux qui ont péché
et ceux sont
repentis
mais cela
ne signifie pas
pour autant
leur redonner
les manteaux
de leur échec
surtout
si ces hommes
sont
désqualifiés
en même
et ont perdu
leur droit de diriger
agir ainsi
n'est pas biblique
et
est abaissé
la norme
établie par Dieu
ici c'est un texte
de MacArthur
à propos
de la disqualification
donc la disqualification
peut être
identifiée
avant même l'appel
mais ici
il est en train
de parler
des hommes
qui ont commis
des péchés
disqualifiés
c'est à dire
qu'ils ont tombé
des paramètres
qu'on vient de considérer
envers l'appel
et donc lui
il est de cette position
où un péché
disqualificateur
compte avec les pardons
de l'église
il reste membre
mais il ne compte pas
avec la restauration
envers les ministères
et ça c'est juste
un appel
pour nous
un rappel pour nous
de l'importance
de bien évaluer
cet appel
si quelqu'un peut continuer
pendant la majeure partie
du siècle
et dernier
les chrétiens conservateurs
se sont concentrés
sur la bataille
sur la pureté
d'Occine
et c'est une bonne chose
mais nous sommes en train
de perdre la bataille
sur la pureté
d'Occine
certaines des pires
des fêtes
ont le réterminé
les leaders
les plus longues
l'église
ne peut pas abaisser
ses standards
pour les athéniens
avec beaucoup peur
elle doit les aider
avant de retrouver
sa vie
si nous échouons ici
alors nous avons
tout un jeu
peu importe
à quel point
notre profession
de soi est orthodoxe
nous ne pouvons pas
être le seul
et la lumière
si nous pouvons
pour l'échange
des standards
de vie
de pureté morale
pour nos dirigeants
ça s'applique
aux anciens
et aux diacres
et pour finir
pour les dirigeants
de votre vie
s'en aller
les systèmes
en courant de l'église
c'est à savoir
que vous suivez
leur exemple
de sécurité
comprenez
qu'ils ne sont pas partis
mais continuez
malgré tout
à nous appeler
à vivre
au standard
de santé
et de sécurité
l'église doit avoir
des liens
véritablement
de notre chambre
tout ce qui est
en dessous de cela
est une âge
et une adhérentie
Amen